يمكن ان نكون اخر جيلا لرغبات الامازون
هذا ما قاله البروفيسور سيمون ويكلوك بعد
الدراسه توصلت الى ان انهيارات النظم
البيئيه المتوقعه جراء التغيرات المناخيه
والاحتباس الحراري قد تحدث بوقت اقرب مما
توقعته دراسات سابقه مؤلف الدراسه توقعوا
انهيارا كارثيا للنظام غابات الامازون
استنادا الى ان 15% من الانهيارات البيئيه
حدثت نتيجه ضغوطا مستجده مثل الاحتباس
الحراري وظواهر الجويه المتطرفه وتلوث
الانهار من اعمال التعدين وتناقص اشجار
الغابات لكن ما الذي يعنيه الانهيار
البيئي دراسات تعرفه بحاله تعاني فيها
مكونات نظام بيئيا ما كالحيوانات او
الاشجار الموجوده فيه من نقص حاد في
تغذيتها وقد يؤدي الى انقراضها تدريجيا
لعدم قدره النظام على تعويض النقص